hi friends uh we are right in the middle
of shooting some new episodes of the
pete holm show coming back on february
24th but in the meantime here's the
answer to some of your meet pete
valentine's day questions that you
submitted on the internet adrian cochran
she wants to know who was saint
valentine great question adrian if i'm
remembering this correctly saint
valentine was born on valentine's day he
was born in a manger and three wise men
came with gifts a diaper
one brought a bow and another brought an
arrow from that day on little saint
valentine or cupid would go around
flying and shoot unsuspecting people
with an arrow and then those two people
would fall in love after having survived
together the traumatic experience of
almost being killed by a baby this next
one comes from robert klein i have to
assume the famous comedian
he says my girlfriend steals the bed
covers for me every night
help here's my suggestion for you robert
is i think instead of sleeping with
traditional sheets top sheet cover sheet
maybe a duvet
what you should do is sleep in
individual sleeping bags but close to
each other that way you can be toasty
and warm but you still have
well-established boundaries both in your
relationship and literally in your
cocoons then if she starts stealing your
sleeping bag she's doing it on purpose
and i suggest couples counseling
kimberly baird has a great question she
says pete what is a deal breaker for you
when you're on a first date uh pretty
standard stuff really too much hair um
not enough hair
too shy um too outgoing doesn't think
i'm funny uh it's funnier than me either
way
you're out has a lot of cats
that's a deal-breaker also doesn't like
cats bit of a deal breaker fear of
ghosts is a ghost thinks in the movie
ferris bueller ferris bueller is the
villain a duster doesn't see the flaws
of ferris bueller as a character can't
drive is always driving
even if it's just a couple blocks
we'll walk the other direction to get
her car just to drive those two blocks
just love driving uh fear of getting on
a helicopter won't get off the
helicopter gloves going into water
slides uh is currently stuck inside of a
water slide these are
i will not date you if you are currently
stuck inside a water slide
you know it's a pretty pretty normal
normal stuff
thanks so much for your wonderful
questions guys i hope you have a safe
safe and wonderful valentine's day and
remember it is valentine's day not
valentine's day that's real okay stop
saying it that way and please be sure to
subscribe to us on youtube and watch the
pete home show when we're back february
24th february it's a hard month to say
give me march
march